have you ever wondered how a country can
be hijacked how institutions can be
subjected perverted and corrupted and
perhaps most importantly how to identify
the moments in which a democracy after
being taken over stops working
dear viewer those questions have
pervaded global politics but especially
they've pervaded Latin American politics
like an interferon even at least you say
they do that if the money theater new
permanent a question on en polvo
Vallauris traditional asymmetrical true
he assumed a mucho
[Music]
for the last few decades numerous Latin
American leaders have taken control of
their countries sometimes they did it
through coup d'etat smut in many other
occasions these dictators came to power
through democratic means that is
precisely the case of Nicaraguan
President Daniel Ortega their official
politic we've already told you about
this political figure how he came to
power how he behaved and how he was
responsible for the huge strikes that
Nicaragua has been going through in 2018
[Music]
strikes that have been answered with a
heavy hands and which have led to
terrible consequences more than 200
people have lost their lives hundreds
have been detained and thousands have
been injured well in this video we're
going to take a look at another aspect
of the events this this is the story of
how a governments managed to take
control of the state and make the
institution's work not for the country
but for itself this is the story of how
a kinds of political mafia took control
of Nicaragua so listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
via its 2006 and Daniel Ortega wins the
Nicaraguan presidential elections after
16 years as the opposition Li sandanista
leader returned to the country's
presidency the presidents weren't
exactly good his first term as president
between 1985 and 1990 was frankly
terrible Ortega left and economically
and socially shattered country it was a
country that went through a war ended up
with a foreign debt six times bigger
than its gdp and suffered from
hyperinflation that reached the
astronomical figure of 33.5 for 7% by
1987 to give you an idea of the
magnitude of this disaster in 1990 the
per capita income of Nicaragua was 55%
smaller than the country had registered
back in 1978
in other words compared to Daniel Ortega
even the Kirchner's would get good
grades
[Music]
folks Ortega's economic model it was a
huge failure the expropriations the
gigantic foreign debt the unstoppable
money printing and his obsession with
controlling the economy all led
Nicaragua into an unsustainable
situation and I mean how wouldn't it
have with that recipe
[Music]
and if we add the contras conflicts to
all of this financed by the united
states the country was submerged in a
complete disaster
[Music]
by the way for those of you who don't
know the Contras were paramilitary
groups financed via Washington through
selling weapons to Iran when this
country was in the middle of a war with
Iraq a country that was supposedly close
to Washington in short a lot of nonsense
so throughout the following decades the
country only had one omission that was
simply to recover from this hideous mess
[Music]
to do this the following government
starting with that of Violetta two more
by the way the first elected female
Latin American president decided to turn
the country's political and economic
approach right around that is to move
from a centralized economy which was
organized and directed by the state to a
market economy
[Music]
that's how the nicaraguan free trade
zones were born Nance well as the
policies to attract foreign investment
which along with international
cooperation and especially the growing
remittances from abroad allowed
Nicaragua to get back on track
[Music]
[Applause]
but hold on just a moment here because
what these new governments didn't
achieve was putting an end to corruption
thus scandal after scandal the feeling
of frustration disappointment and
deceits that all Nicaraguans felt along
with an opposition who was willing to do
almost anything to return to power
fueled
Ortega's victory in 2006 and here dear
viewers is where the new story begins
especially because ortega wasn't going
to waste his return to power this was
his chance this was his opportunity to
dominate a Nicaraguan politics finances
and society but to achieve this and
above all to prevent an electoral
process from reacting him from the
presidency he needed to seize political
power with an armed force and an
economic monopoly this is the strategy
he set in motion and the steps he took
to achieve his purpose so listen up
[Music]
political power
obviously his strategies first goal was
to achieve political hegemony and social
control by any means necessary this was
very clear to ortega from the beginning
and he launched a double tactic to
achieve it first by invading the
institutions and centralizing power and
then by limiting and intimidating the
opposition something for which fear is
usually a very very effective ingredient
therefore shortly after arriving Ortega
launched a paramilitary force composed
of gang members we're talking about
shocked groups better known in Nicaragua
as the terrors they are feared and the
people call them mobs they usually wear
t-shirts that speak of love and peace
wear helmets to hide their faces and
move on motorcycles they're mostly very
violent young people my field a court of
the wild journalists in Managua its
objective well that would be to
intimidate the political opposition to
frighten those who disagree with the
government and to try and dismantle the
opposition's demonstrations or
concentrations with violence obviously
it isn't an official force but they have
the government's protection and we're
going to see how that works in just a
moment we can say that a paramilitary
force has been set up in Nicaragua that
is composed of gang members sometimes we
get on a bus and the paramilitary member
is watching us hi they Castillo
Nicaraguan activist but of course it
doesn't end here the next step to
achieve total political control is to
take control of the state institutions
and well how do you think he did that
[Applause]
[Music]
well first political decentralization
had to be ended in this case municipal
autonomy thus in Nicaragua Ortega's
political henchmen have managed to
dismiss mayor's at will something like
hey if you've got a political rival just
kick him out of the race that way you
don't need to get rid of your opponents
you also win loyal fans who of course
don't a risk making you mad right
the second step to institutional
takeover was to create and legitimize
his own political organizations in this
case the citizen power councils these
bodies which supposedly involve
community participation in practice have
the objective of creating a parallel
political structure that is recognized
and controlled by the government and the
third appoint and achieved the
indefinite permanence of his party
associates in every key state position
the electoral power the judicial power
and the general comptroller
and if an official protests I mean
that's what those mobs are for right so
how about two examples of proving or
Ortega achieved with this strategy well
check this out
[Music]
all the one hands the Nicaraguan
Constitution prohibited the consecutive
re-election of a president so Ortega
would have completed his turn in 2011
however as Hernandez did in Honduras
Ortega managed to get the constitutional
chamber of the Supreme Court composed
mostly of sandanista magistrate's to
declare article 147 as inapplicable
which is the one that prevented the
presidential consecutive reelection in
exchange
yep themed magistrates positions were
insured for life quite the exchange
on the other hand in 2011 fraud
suspicions were so intense that both the
European Union and the Organization of
American States concluded that they
weren't sure of the results you know who
controlled the electoral power
yes it would be Ortega and he made sure
that his followers could do and undo
whatever they want it in fact in the
following elections the 2016 ones they
didn't even split and the ruling party
took full control of the process but
hold on a moment you might be thinking I
mean wasn't there a big scandal because
of this silent well let's say that the
president had made sure that practically
every major media station in the country
was controlled by his family of their
associates your take a family
monopolizes the media in nicaragua mobs
and the occupation of institutions and
the media well this is the political
side but there's much more the force
monopoly of course for as much as he
holds political power if a dictator
doesn't hold the military force he's
taking a huge risk this was very clear
to our protagonist so the second pillar
of this strategy was to take over the
police and to take over the army to do
so he took advantage of his majority in
the National Assembly as soon as he got
power Ortega pushed a reform that placed
the ability to appoint new faculties of
the National Police and the army of the
Republic in his hands then taking
advantage of these new possibilities he
faced relatives and loyal people
directly in charge of these institutions
for example the police are directed by
his own father-in-law Francisco Diaz
this means he can get the police to look
the other way when the mobs accent and
the opposition strikes repression
repression and well more repressions
[Music]
because when the Mafia holds the power
it's not easy for them to let go well
we've covered politics and we've covered
force but there's still a third element
missing economic power
the third pillar in the strategy was to
achieve economic power for three reasons
first to prevent a Nicaraguan capital
from supporting an alternative second to
get resources with which to carry out
Ortega's plans and third perhaps the
most important points to fill his
pockets
throughout this time corruption has been
brutal to such an extent that the Ortega
Murillo family a millionaire's see
they've taken over the media they hold
high positions in the States they've
even taken over oil important
distributions in here arguer they put
themselves in charge of the investments
promotion agencies with a plan that we
could describe like this once you invest
in Nicaragua great we'll make it happen
but you have to give me a commission you
know for that country they've also
reached agreements with businessman
apparently by getting loyalty and
envelopes in exchange for privileges a
clear example of this way of doing
things was the agreements made she
builds the interoceanic canal a
seemingly unsuccessful projects first in
which the government reached an
under-the-table agreement with one
dredge in the chinese developer working
on it at first the state kept half of
the profits and then with the
last-minute change it became one percent
obviously the businessman did some
last-minute haggling
in short dear viewer the fact is that
with political power with brute force
and with economic power Daniel Ortega
became the owner and Lord of Nicaragua
and also a billionaire and just in case
in the last election in 2016 he
presented Rosario Murillo his wife as
vice president
so everything that certainly stays in
the family
[Music]
if you were this is essentially the same
thing that happens in Venezuela it is so
to speak for manual for a dictator and
the question we can ask ourselves now is
can we really pretend that Nicaragua is
still a democracy well leave your
opinion in the comment section below and
as always have you found this video
interesting don't forget to subscribe to
visual politic if you haven't already
done that and I really hope you enjoyed
this video don't forget to check out
reconsider media they do a podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode it's
all great stuff also as always this
channel it's possible because of patreon
and our patrons on patreon please
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Applause]